i've ended the youtube membership
channel that i started only a week ago
i did this for a number of reasons first
i realized that the purpose of my
channel is that we can learn
about ourselves and about each other not
a whole lot of learning is going to
happen with 500 to 700 people
subscribing to my
my channel i also didn't feel good about
posting these shortened versions of my
videos
trying to entice people to come to the
membership channel that just didn't sit
right with me
but the bigger problem was that so many
people were having a hard time
finding the join button if you have an
iphone you couldn't find the join button
to
join this membership channel if you went
to the link and joined that way
then iphone users couldn't find the
videos
youtube support was of no use in this
they were they were absolutely useless
and uh
that left me with one option to end it
and refund everyone's money which is
what i'm doing
so i'm going back to uploading
everything full length on my free
youtube channel
the demonetized videos that were on my
membership channel that i posted in the
last week
will be reposted on free youtube in the
next week or so
as i said before this was an experiment
and this certainly is not the solution
but i don't even know if there is a
solution to my problem
youtube controls my ability to make
money with their demonetization of my
videos and there's not much i can do
about that
patreon is not the answer because it
lacks the search tools lacks the ability
to link other videos and
that doesn't it's not as user friendly
as youtube is
but if youtube's going to continue
deleting my videos as they've been doing
in the last week
i've noticed i'm not comfortable with
youtube as a home for my channel any
longer so
i'm not sure what the future is but for
the time being you get your videos for
free on youtube
thank you for subscribing you'll get
your money back hopefully shortly and
thank you for watching